we took a discussion of secular fans of
anthropology of secularism ND that
signal ism is not just a principle but
you know is is its own right of
formation of cultures and beliefs and
applied that concept to press reports
needs categories of missionary
strategies parachurch organizations
would seculars and not still have a
chance to self you know have the ability
to apply those kinds of strategies build
up those kinds of organizations have the
appropriate secular state relations and
still have to be able to adapt in the
same way the sense that anything make
its own resurgence it could you know I
mean they need to invent a new ideology
because sort of the two you know the two
big versions of that you know which were
fascism and communism are basically you
know for all you know as far as we know
extinct I mentioned them because those
are you know those are or those are
movements which really did did build you
know complex ritual life you know kind
of a fully developed you know cosmology
of one kind or another you know
extensive networks of various kinds of
you know parachurch organizations you
know papers etc etc etc you know
interestingly to some degree in response
to it responds to an interaction with
particularly Catholic kind of
confessional movements during that
during the 19th century there's a lot of
interplay interaction between those two
and interestingly that some of the few
places where you actually find
Protestants replicating that or places
where they are in direct competition
with both Catholic and socialist
Socialist Movement Netherlands is the
classic example of this
you find this also to some extent with
in Austria Belgium and lesser degree
some some parts of Germany and I think
there are there are actually these
organizations I mean that in Turkey
definitely there's this attempt to
organize against Islamist there is a you
know foundation to support modern life
that that's one for example it's that
kind of has also chaired the functions
but it different did they want to
propagate kind of defense secularism
against kind of a realization of of
public life in Turkey and in Germany too
I mean those of the kind of immigrant
organizations that were based in Turkey
were actually nationalist and secular
and they did actually experience lots of
tension with the established
organizations as they competed over kind
of immigrants you know to to provide
their you know primary kind of
organizations although now now the
detention has ceased and in the German
context the Islamic organizations were
much more successful because because
they were also oriented around most
communities whereas the other
organizations didn't have this kind of
thing I mean the religion provides a
very kind of ready-made language and you
know for for these organizations that
enables them to much easily much easier
attract attract immigrants workers then
let's say some of these other
alternative organizations were as a
socialist than you know so they didn't
have the same kind of connection so that
I think to kind of cultural idioms and
languages that this kind of religious
communal language did and it's actually
the these secular organizations gave up
because they saw that they needed to
collaborate with the Islamic
organizations if they wanted to claim
any kind of power or representation / /
immigrants because their members should
numbers were really low we just work
very quick little follow-on which is
that there's a way in which at least
liberal secularism is in some ways at a
disadvantage and that kind
of a struggle in the same way that
liberal Protestantism isn't for exactly
the same reason because is extremely
intellectual istic and non ritualistic
character and I think that you know I
mean that's both one of the things which
is admirable about liberal secularism
and liberal Protestant but also one of
the things we should weakens them
politically secularist organizations so
they tend to be born into it the way
that presumably members of the
swans are or are they people that come
out of the religious ones or are they
sort of yeah actually I don't know I
that's an interesting question but their
federal backgrounds are and what kind of
implants that they come they come from
it's really good to know this was
certainly with some of this so like if
you look at the second late 19th century
secular societies you know in England in
particular you know they do actually try
to it you know they have their own
sunday schools which are supposed to be
a kind of arrival to conventional sunday
schools and they something to try to
replicate you know this whole sort of
menu of different kinds of organizations
and so filled up in association of life
and people it is and that's not the kind
of a Creed you know into which people
are born and it's ass on you know we all
kind of know about the red diaper babies
i think or maybe only my generation
knows about that about you know sort of
1930s 40s activists in the ways in which
they kind of passed on their you know
their political commitments and so on to
their children I mean obviously that
that can happen but
that's best I got the answer I could be
where they tend to be inter
international I mean like right divert
ladies it wasn't but theoretically like
that the ataturk pin where's it's very
specifically nationalistic I mean in
case of Turkey I don't know what your
balance k so thoroughly definitely there
was one generation that was the early
Republican generation that saw itself as
part of progress and a new turkey and
and they do come from certain
backgrounds I don't know what their
family kind of background is necessarily
but they come for example teachers I
mean this generation of you know early
Republican teachers was really kind of
invested in this kind of secularizing
and westernizing identity and there is
definitely probably probably a
continuation of those of those groups